I have a really interesting video to look
at with you today.
We are truly seeing the worst of what dishonest
and incompetent administration is capable
of.
Dr. Sima Burma was interviewed by Fox News's
Martha MacCallum.
Now, Dr. Vermont is the administrator of the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid Services
in the Trump administration and part of the
Corona Virus Task Force.
She went on Fox News and was asked six times
by Martha MacCallum very specific questions
about the number of tests I see use and ventilators
available for Corona virus, OK. Trump has
been insisting for weeks anyone who wants
to test can get it, can get a test.
They can't.
That's not true.
Trump has been saying people who are flying
into the country are being tested.
No, they're not.
There's sometimes just having their temperature
taken, Trump says.
There are more than enough tests.
There are not.
Trump pretends like our cases numbers are
accurate because we're testing so many people.
We're not the numbers aren't accurate.
We might have half a
million people currently infected.
And I have to say, this is not praise of anything
other than Martha MacCallum.
In these five minutes, OK, it's not praise
of Martha in general.
It's not praise of Fox News.
It's merely Martha MacCallum realized she
was being snowed.
She does a good job of exposing this Trump
robot who can't stop lying and can't answer
a single question.
So I'm in a play for you, a bunch of questions
which essentially ask the same thing.
What is the number of actual tests available?
What about the ICU use?
What about the ventilators?
And you will notice how every single time
Dr. Sima, Vermont just talks about something
different.
And Martha MacCallum tries to bring her back.
And Dr. Verma just again answers about something
else.
When even Fox News host have to expose a Trump
bot for obvious lies and deception, you
know, they're being more deceptive and dishonest
than usual.
Let's get right into it.
My pleasure.
How are we doing on these tests?
I remember last week, I believe Alex Azar,
the HHS secretary, said that there would be
millions of them out there by the end of the
week.
Has that happened?
You know, our focus is on making sure that
people that need tests can get tests.
And so one of the things that's already available
is that at every public health laboratory
across the nation, these tests are available.
But we're working on now is to increase the
capacity in the private health care system,
because most of us, when we go get tests,
we don't go to a public health lab.
You're used to going to your doctor's office.
They order the tests.
And that usually is handled through our private
health care system.
And so we've been working with the private
system to essentially ramp up so we can make
sure that those tests are available.
Our focus is on making sure people who need
the tests get it.
So we're working on capacity at private versus
public.
It's not an answer.
So Martha MacCallum tries again.
You promised millions of tests by now and
we don't have the right doc.
So is it true that there are millions of those?
It's now almost the end of the week.
So has that mark been met that we heard about
from Secretary Azar?
Because I was at a doctor for something else
the other morning and asked and they said,
you know, we can't get them.
We've been calling.
We called the state.
We called here.
We can't we can't get our hands on them.
And then I heard it from another doctor earlier
today with the same story with a patient that
that she wanted to test.
And she tried to get a test for that patient
and was unable to do so.
Well, today, one of the things that we did,
Dr. Hahn and I hosted a call with over sixteen
hundred representatives from hospitals to
work with them around how they can do the
testing inside their hospital laboratories.
The other thing that we're focused on is preparing
the entire health care system.
Some of the conversations that we've been
having with hospitals is making sure that
they have again, no answer.
Question is, you promised millions of tests.
My doctor says they have none.
She answers will listen.
We've been having phone calls with hospital
reps about testing in hospitals.
We've issued guidance, no tests, no answer.
And Martha MacCallum is starting to get irritated.
She filibustered there for more than a minute.
Eventually, again, Martha MacCallum manages
to get a word in and asks another time.
And this time she says, well, we have ICU
shortages, we have ventilator shortages.
We have shortages of equipment to do tests,
OK?
But in terms of actual equipment, we heard
Bernie Sanders today, for one, coming out
and saying that there's a major shortage of
ICU units.
We've heard that there's a shortage of ventilators,
even swabs and equipment for the actual tests.
What's being done about that?
And how concerned are you that when when these
numbers do start to rise, which Dr. Fouchier's
told us to expect, that they'll be enough
ICU units, enough ventilators to help the
people who do get sick in this country?
Well, that's why we have an emergency preparedness
system.
You know, we were used to dealing with disasters
if we look at some of the disasters that have
happened.
Hurricanes in Puerto Rico and Florida.
There is a system in place to make sure that
folks that are on the front lines have the
equipment and the supplies that they need.
Are you saying that we do have now we're doing
it.
See, a mass is to have rapid dialog with health
care providers.
So we're meeting with providers.
Well, we have a system, but the question was
about equipment.
Oh, but there's no answer to that.
We have a system.
We have meetings.
We have guidance.
They have plenty of dialog and guidance, clearly.
But what about the equipment?
More filibustering about tests and equipment.
Martha comes back in again, and this time
Dr. Seyma won't even let her ask again.
Just talking over Martha MacCallum, the needs
that they have.
Yeah, I think that we've really had one more
time.
Will there be enough sure that people understand,
hey, before you go into your doctor's office,
you can call your doctor on the phone and
have a discussion with them and they can tell
you whether you need to come in or not.
And that's really important because we don't
want to have people travel unnecessarily if
they're not feeling well.
Now, I've said if they if they come into a
health care facility, they could also be putting
others at risk.
Martha tried to ask again and the doctor just
said, you know, call your doctor, have a discussion.
Eventually, Martha MacCallum gets to ask one
more time.
And this one is just nuts.
Dr. Verma goes directly into saying Trump
has been bold and decisive.
And check out the look on Martha McCallum's
face.
She can't believe it.
It's a smirk of disgust as the last big lie
is told.
And Dr. birma knew it was a five minute interview
and this was the last 30 seconds praised Trump
and avoid answering the question.
I'm sure that that providers can use tell
it telehealth and telemedicine.
Right on to serve their pay.
We've made that point here quite, quite a
bit.
I think it's a very important point to make.
But before I let you go, I want to ask you
one more time.
Are there going to be people in this country
who don't get a ventilator if they need one?
Are you concerned that the actual physical
equipment that is needed to serve the people
who will get sick is out there?
Can you reassure everyone tonight that there
is not a shortage of ventilators or ICU units?
And that's why the president has taken such
a bold and decisive action.
Right.
We're not waiting for this to get worse.
We're not waiting for this to be a crisis
in our health care systems.
And that's why the mitigation strategies that
he announced last night, limiting travel from
Europe, not allowing that.
You know, we've given travel advisories on
cruise ships.
That's why we're taking all of this action,
because we don't want to put stress on the
health care system.
OK.
That that's not a direct answer to the question,
but it sounds like a hope that there won't
be enough sick people and we won't run that
one right out.
Van ventilators, because we have mitigated.
And we certainly hope that.
We certainly hope that's the case.
Guys, this was five minutes.
Martha MacCallum asked five times, tried to
ask six times.
Was only able to ask five times about tests
and ventilators and ICU use.
And there was not a single factual answer
from this Trump.
But who just.
It's almost like her software malfunctioned
and she just kept repeating the answers to
a different.
She was working off of a script for a different
interview.
It didn't matter.
She loaded up that script and read it for
this interview.
And it's dishonest.
It's disgusting.
And, you know, this is nothing other than
saying at least here, Martha MacCallum kept
asking and said those aren't really answers
to my questions.
What else can we do that they're just not
going to be straight with us?
Fox News